ah look who we have on the phone on the
celebrity hotline calling in hello hello
hi how you doing good and love you look
oh I hope they told you to say that
before you called it yeah the screener
told me Travis that test or something
yes can say that a very good guys
congratulations on your program well
thank you buddy
thank you a very tired Anthony qu Mia
who is up late last night watching the
big WikiLeaks presentation Oh were you
up late watching that nothing nothing
happened it was terrible he plugged his
book and I just would I was expecting
something and then we got nothing out of
it who thought the jeweler signs will
take a [ __ ] page out of the Jim
Norton plug book that's how I did yeah
that was a non-event though uh but you
know eh I'll get up early to talk with
Jim Norton Sam Roberts No thank you
network by the way my favorite thing of
you right now and I've loved it for a
long time is that photo of you in the
[ __ ] shark from Jaws that may laser
oh my god do I love the awful sock that
jacket is great with the anchors and
their Vaughn jacket and it's good for
all occasions I could literally wear
that to a wedding and it wouldn't anger
anybody we're in a show a collector's
item
yeah I know I I should wear it on the
show but uh where did you buy that where
did you buy the jacket or do you have
that made I didn't that was made
custom-made there were the jackets all
wasn't available you would think that
thing would be all over the place no you
wouldn't buy it and I would not do that
popular item
Asaf I do not think that at all hey uh
yeah Halloween party this year uh yes as
a matter of fact I think the theme is
the 70s television Oh perfect all right
yeah we usually have a theme over here
gonna be seventies TV so I've anything
from you know Columbo we maybe wha
Columbo it may it may be technically in
the 80s but
I think Jim would want addresses a
special guest star on a very special
episode of Diff'rent Strokes that
involves Dudley and Arnold oh yes I want
to dress as mr. Carlson and WKRP in
Cincinnati on dr. Johnson yeah yeah that
will get a few of the tops from the
neighborhood to us reenact the whole
thing accurately so am I invited to your
Halloween party of course
okay well mr. Sam Roberts I don't know I
want to go me click it you two are great
I can't even I can't even believe it
after all said and done there you two
doing a goddamn show thank you very much
we just hope it's popular we're
demanding lobby photos we're really
[ __ ] annoyed that there's no photo in
the lobby
yeah man they must be going nuts trying
to figure out the photos and everything
nuts over there
you gotta I guess you gotta give him a
week or so trying to figure out what the
shows are and what the channel is in
which Italy yeah what the channel is the
shows who's there who's not that's what
I tried to like explain to people and
you know that as much speculation is
going on it's not like anybody here was
holding back information
it's literally that's how the decisions
are made like that's when the decisions
are made like you'll know when we know
which is probably the night before
really Sam I I never knew that yes
sometimes they use spring information
very very cool how is your show not that
good I'm having a blast
tonight as a matter of fact at seven
o'clock uh East Side Dave remember East
Side Dave don't you yes yes yeah he he
put together a whole Star Wars thing and
everybody uh from my whole network was
involved in the re-enacting Star Wars so
it's a whole Star Wars extravaganza
which airs tonight are you cause all um
well it's well I guess we could but it
but it's following the script and
everything and it's all
act it out wonderfully the it's Star
Wars done by us but now have you filmed
this already
oh yeah it's all done it's ready to roll
at 7:00 I'm going to watch it and I know
a lot of the people associated with your
network the big question on everybody's
mind is what role will be filled by
daniel bobo kerlun Daniel Bobo Berlin
was an amazing are too deeply going
around going oh be cool like a beeps
beep all right yeah yeah yeah light on
his head ya know how the hell I ended up
in custody of all of them everybody went
with you you got big a and you got both
like who are you playing in a Star Wars
you really got a [ __ ] divorce
headache
oh yeah yeah yeah I got I got I had to
support all the kids so you know first
of all who's we know who big a is now
does he have to are to cryofreeze han
Solo
that's that's uh - that was a UH Empire
Strikes Back you in the home effects
back this is one and he's a he said
Tarkin so he's a up plump apartment
which was talking to Tarkin uh one of
the Empire bigwigs yeah he's like the
the Grand Moff with that Peter Cushing
role yeah oh okay okay
big a much body Casting that's very bad
casual there there's some dialogue that
goes back and forth because I'm not
Darth Vader
so there's a dialogue that goes back and
forth between him and I and I'm just
standing there waiting for him to get
out you know just you have all the
outfits and everything very psyched
about that what's that you got all the
outfits and everything um well the
Hostelling budget wasn't really at hot
oh um yeah so some of the costumes are a
little on the budget side but uh you get
that you get the message you know who
everyone is
- who else plays who you a balloon who
is uh David II thought dave is Luke
Davis Luke you are Vader Bobo is aren't
you too big a Peter Cushing who else
yeah and then we got uh Roy from Dave
show is uh Han and then a flute she is
Princess Leia ah looks great uh yeah I
really wanted to see stalker patty as
Princess Leia
Lucy's hot that would have been
something but but no um it's yeah flute
see and let's see Gavin McInnes is a
c-3po does an amazing job
oh no c-3po and then there's extra guest
stars for various stormtroopers and and
other things I have to do I'm looking at
I'm looking at a photo online right now
in somebody's Twitter account and Bobo
is Bobo is wearing what appears to be an
orange t-shirt and he's got some kind of
blue Matt duct taped to him so it looks
like he doesn't have legs and then he's
got a miners flashlight on his head good
and some wrap now minor huh and some
some wrap around his jaw to the top of
his head yeah
yes actually as a paper plate takes the
top of his head now to save a few bucks
if he took the advice of Eastside Dave
as far as costumes go paper plate to the
head is like you're serving serving uh
Oh pups
I thought that I saw I almost bombed and
I stopped him is this what this new show
is going to play yeah just not me
eagerly trying to get our Bobo as a
piece of [ __ ] jokes and floppy that was
Bobo instructed to keep his hands firmly
planted against his side so it
he was a robot yeah yeah boop boop throw
up yeah very very cold should be a lot
of uh a lot of fun no nya Paul Mercurio
on today at 4:00 he's uh you might know
Paul Mercurio you ever hear of a legend
I have yeah we met sir I actually like
Paulie I seem at the comedy show about
Paul's great yeah we we uh you know
after the the sex for Sam thing of years
ago uh where you know Paul was the the
guy that was taking that couple that had
sex at st. Pat's Cathedral he was the
one taking them around and uh you know
there was a lot of blaming going back
and forth for many years but they sit
down and hash it out and he's uh he's a
pisser everywhere so over there the
Colbert show doing warm-up and writing
and stuff so uh yeah hit me on it at
four how did he go over to the network
from Comedy Central yeah yeah so he's
over over there at CBS doing that and
then uh yeah you guys still morning huh
geez morning yeah you know I kind of
wanted it I kind of sorry buddy I kind
of wanted the morning I mean you know
yeah I got you I got I got used to
living the Anthony lifestyle though that
he lives because I was at night and it
was like you go to bed at like 4:30 in
the morning you wake up and any
lifestyle what is that so you wake up
drunk in a strange crib you see bars and
you have to figure out if it's a holding
cell no or a crib and you know did I get
lucky yeah you uh you have to get
regimented regimented now don't ya yeah
now I have to go back into like life
where you wake up in the morning and you
go to sleep at night and it's it's not
it's not easy no it really isn't and you
got a do you do you nap right when you
get home now or something because that's
the only way you could have any kind of
a life Oh God yeah I luckily we're
starting a number that we start at 8 now
which is like okay love you
oh my god a lot of people complained
about the eight so you know we're going
to see if we have to keep it at eight
and what we can do you know because it
helps across the country it's different
in different time zones across the
country but I don't know yeah yeah we'll
love to see yeah I'll have to see yeah
now it's it's so cool though man I'm uh
I'm real happy for you guys we uh thank
you buddy
Troy and Troy were talking about you the
other day because we were both good I
hope y'all it was good we both love the
fact that you've gone from like goofing
on Alex Jones and doing the Alex Jones
impressions and everything to actually
like being a part of the thing you're an
Infowars guy now he is my guy he's the
false my guy yes I do uh I do the last
hour of his show every other Thursday I
do the three to three to four hour on in
force.com over uh over there on every
other Thursday so uh it's great you just
get on there and and passionately yell
into the camera about Hillary and
everything it's great that's it and you
know Falls like a spider goes there's a
they're mutating of spiders put them
together what ghosts making sliders
fantastic I definitely I dig it I like
he's hilarious
aliens hilarious just cracks me up uh
with some of the stuff he comes out with
and uh no I'm real happy to be doing
that have you met him I Dino Ellis Jones
did you know him or just from doing this
not not in person no I never met him in
person but uh ii-i've done his show
numerous times um from my studio and you
know we just hit it off and uh and he
had me do it the last hour of the show
and now every other Thursday I'm doing
that one so it's a it's pisser it's a
lot of fun and then of course I see
Sammy Roberts on redeye yeah every so
often that's that's cool uh I wish they
put us on together though doing that
they should I know that would be great
imagine if it was all three of us the
ratings to go through the roof
that's just the two would probably yeah
it was fine great but we don't read I
what if you got like blue eyes or
something
[ __ ] yeah I was gonna say that stole my
[ __ ] joke you piece of garbage
those texting at home I'm like wait till
I say this they're gonna crack up words
I just saw you you were texting uh do
you miss Travis what that exactly I said
do you miss track like that long pause
Oh what I didn't hear that just a clot
yes same answer what's that exactly a
sneeze in a toilet flush 100 that's um
I saw that one who posted that it set up
he didn't answer you've you've heard
that you've heard the best now here's
who's here who's left Errol
you heard the best out here what's left
right what laughs oh that's bill funny
and then Jim your videos are infuriating
salad with aa thing
it is I I didn't know I was getting an
anxiety attack watching it why it's a
new show popular it's to the people I I
can't imagine that it's popular for a
new show there's anything that you
trying to instigate people to get upset
well what's the other one at work
there's two of them but there was
actually a fire so that shows on hiatus
because there's a fire the refrigerator
the water one uh which what was that
call fridge water Follies Ridge
waterfall with with you crackling zuv
the plastic water bottle why I had to
move a mustard it was yes first you move
must and then when the water bottle tips
over I it's angering you're angering to
us
I love how many times you watched it
though that you know every moment of
yeah you really remembers a pruder film
you've analyzed this I could not look
away the
the horror thank you this more to come
more to come oh thank goodness
salad with Jim is on hiatus it will be
back there's an uproar fridge water
Follies right now I'll take it off so
we'll see what's next that's fantastic
we'll come in see you soon two men will
come and see you soon yeah yeah that
would be very cold come on in and you
know talk about what what life is like
doing a popular morning radio show oh
very cool
we won't know what's good talking you
brother you know that yeah that's cool
oh man
I'm real happy for you guys and yeah
come on by definitely I will talk again
soon thank you alright pal take it easy
man party later and you can check
Anthony out obviously you know I think
four to six today on the Anthony ku Mia
Network and you can you know go to an
Twitter or whatever if you want a link
yeah Anthony Kumi comm every comm take
you there to everything he said a lot of
fun shows going on over there it's good
to hear from him again yes absolutely
and then there's that that [ __ ] Star
Wars thing with Bobo oh I can't wait to
like that or if it's just gonna upset me
too much why would it upset you just to
see him going to be bleep me
just because of how infuriating you
would have been to deal with the entire
time he's doing it yeah green screen
though he's taking advantage of having
that green screen yes he is